We can easily calculate the probability for discrete samples like this one in a
discrete population, but what about in real life, with huge populations? We
can't possibly calculate the mean of every possible sample of size n and even if
we could, we wouldn't want to. We ended up with 16 samples when we just had a
population of size 4. What if we had a population of 350 million? Which is often
the case. Well, you've already seen that the distribution of sample means is
normal. And we know that the mean of all these sample means is the population
mean. Remember, the population mean here was 2.5. And the mean of all possible
sample means is also 2.5. So, if we have a random sample and we take the mean of
it, how can we know where it falls on this distribution of sample means. We're
missing one important thing. Do we need to know the total number in the
population? The standard deviation of the distribution of sample means? Which is
this here. Or, the total number of possible samples?